c'est pas une nostalgie clair moi je
pense aussi qu'il faut rétablir une
droiture une base saine dans les
rapports humains de l'enfance jusqu'à la
mort de la naissance jusqu'à la mort
aussi bien l'accouchement que de que
l'amour que les actes amoureux et où
quand il parlait dans sert que de ce que
fait l'amérique qui m'étonne pas trop
parce que comme c'est un système
tellement basée sur la rentabilité le
fric
d'ailleurs maintenant à un moment donné
on se trouve est vraiment dans la merde
parce qu'il ya de plus en plus de gens
sur le carreau
l'histoire s'est on parle d'une faillite
d'une faillite de l'homme par rapport à
où l'argent les banquiers ont pris le
pouvoir et ont des déplacés tout tous
les centres naturel l'éducation de deux
constantes
moi je sais quand j'étais monde c'est
des gens qui m'ont appris c'est c'est en
regardant un type jouer du piano et du
comment tu fais ça je vais te montrer
moi il montrait je ne sais pas forcément
d'aller dans une école et puis de
trouver un autre tiens prends ma guitare
je vais jouer avec toi je me rappelle
henri crolla qui m'avait dit comme ça
j'avais 18 ans est une diva prend la
guitare et joue avec moi j'ai comment tu
fais les accords mets du projet quitte à
jésus mais je sais jouer trois accords
béni c'est déjà ça on va partir de trois
accords on va partir même d'un accord si
tu veux est en fait en jouant avec lui
je le regardais jouer les gars m'ont il
fait comme ça alors je limitais quoi et
on est en limitant j'apprenais il
m'avait après aussi ça s'apprend aussi
parfois d'humour la distance je ris avec
soi même
et puisque ce qu elle fait aussi c'est à
dire mettre en application ce qu'on
pensait le faire
moi j'ai d'autres méthodes si chacun
doit parler de lui bon c'est pas
forcément peut-être intéressant que j'en
parle mais je veux dire je passe
beaucoup de temps aussi à écouter et à
répondre en plus de je veux dire c'est
pas en plus chanter on peut le faire à
0,5 des notions de les choses mais après
aussi à énormément de choses qui sont
importants c'est pour ça que je pense
que tout ce temps là en dehors de ta
propre création c'est très important
on avait aussi j'avais été aussi appelé
par des professeurs qu'ils aient quelque
chose
une femme très super de banlieues bleues
qu'ils aient quelque chose à epinay et
qui m'avait appelé dans un lycée où
j'étais tombé sur des tas de monde comme
ça qu'ils s'étaient mis à écrire des
poèmes et puis je me rappelle de ce pas
ça en fin de ce moment où une jeune
fille avait lu un poème d'amour c'est
qu'à au milieu des petits rappeurs quoi
et puis c'était marc et tout ça et j'ai
laissé aller jusqu'au bout comme c'était
fini je vais vie bat marc panel parce
qu'elle parle d'amour tu vois et en fait
tu te marres parce que tu es gêné et il
s'était marié m'avait regardé ouais
ouais ouais ouais j'ai dit mais en fait
ça devienne un peu qu'on parle d'amour
éléments parlent très bien elle en parle
d'une façon peut-être naïve mais on s'en
fout je dire il n'y avait pas question
d'avoir des civilisations créer des
génies mais c'est un jour aussi jean
marie serreau qui m'avait appris ça il
m'a dit on on n'a pas un jaune d'oeuf
ciapa leblanc autour quoi et d'une
certaine façon on n'a pas des génies
dans une époque le génie humain se
manifeste pas tant qu'il n'y a pas
d'état de tout une création autour
je pense à certaines périodes qui ont
été très très créatif de l'humanité
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de
mouvements générons la société généreux
aussi et d'intelligence de compréhension
du monde d'éducation c'est très très
important ces mêmes capitale mais tout
se tient ensemble et ce qu'on essaye
finalement ce que tout le monde essaye
pour l'instant en dehors du pouvoir des
médias et du pouvoir de la rentabilité
parce que le pouvoir des médias aussi
est basé maintenant sur des chiffres
auxquels on peut tout faire dire quoi 59
% et 25 %
qui sait c'est 25% si tu descends dans
la rue tu parle à quelqu'un ou si tu te
balades un peu et que tu réponds aux
gens que tu les écoutes en tout cas tu
t'aperçois que c'est plus les chiffres
c'est une vraie réalité est qu'il faut
passer du temps faut écouter il faut
prendre le temps
quand j'écris impatience pas tout à fait
vrai mais des fois bon j'ai pas cette
vertu de pouvoirs
par exemple faire ce que tu fais ce que
font avec des gens dans une école mais
j'y participe la mesure c'est pas si tu
m'appelles je viens et je travaille avec
même si c'est aujourd'hui jacques
higelin on va hélas être au bout de
cette émission comprend d'autres choses
avant d'éclore il ya une chose qui me
gêne profondément jusqu'à présent c'est
que on est devant un choix de ceux qui
étaient là maintenant mondiale c'est à
dire qu'il faut vraiment reprendre
toutes les choses et c'est face à ce
cette aggravation réelle pollution
mentale donc pollution de
l'environnement également parce que ça
commence la pollution du coeur position
des sentiments position de la réflexion
et pollution de l'éducation toujours il
ya quelque part quelqu'un qui veut
gagner sur le dos
les autres sur la crédulité des gens
gagné par secte religieuse même plan
gagné tiré du poignon les scientologues
les les autres et tous les autres y
compris la plus vieille secte l'église
catholique qui tirent toujours du pognon
tu connais la pâte les prestations de
l'église catholique à paris ils ont
plein d'imagés est ici ils ont des
immeubles entiers moi je serai un jour
j'étais rentré avec india ça ça
appartient à l'église catholique un
énorme truc vide des fous ou quoi
léger avec cathédrale
[Musique]